well it's hard to believe but we're  coming up on four years since the one  october massacre now you can pay tribute  to the victims and survivors at the  annual vegas strong 5k and one mile race  it's coming up sunday october 3rd at  floyd lamb state park in the far  northwest  if you don't register by today you're  not guaranteed to get the shirt size  that you want it's 45 for the 5k 35 to  sign up for the one mile run  or walk prices go up after september  15th  proceeds go to the one october related  funds like the resiliency center and the  healing garden it's also important to  note they can only have a maximum of 750  participants this year  and they only have about uh maybe 150  spots left so if you'd like to register  you do need to hurry be sure and watch  good day las vegas monday morning i'll  be talking with cynthia gainey the  organizer of from just run  she's organized this event and we'll  talk about what's new for this year  coming up on good day monday morning